للاسف الشديد
وما زال
[موسيقى]
الاحزان بعد يوم خاصه ان جهود الانقاذ
نتيجه للظروف الطقس وغيرها من العوامل
تتظاهر لكن ما احب ان وظيفه هنا انه ما
زالت الجهود مستمره رغم شحه الامكانيات
ولكن هناك هناك جهود تبدل في تقديم
ضحايا هذا
الكارثه الماساويه من خلال توفير
ماوى وكذلك الغذاء وغيرها من الاحتياجات
للاسر التي تضررت من هذا الزلزال طبعا
اريد ان اوضح هنا ان رئيس اللجنه الدوليه
الصليب الاحمر ووفره يوم امس مدينه حلب
وهي الان في زياره لهذه المدينه باطلاع
على اثار هذا الزلزال تاتي هذه الزياره
الاولى لها الى الاشاره الاوسط وكذلك عقب
هذه الماده الانسانيه لتطلع بنفسها على
حجم الدمار وكذلك
التحشيش الجهد الدولي لتقديم المزيد من
الدعم للشعب السوري الذي يعاني من هذه
الكارثه فقط ولكنه يعاني من ازمه انسانيه
ضربت في البلاد اكثر من 12 عاما اثرت على
جميع مفاصل الحياه على كل كل المرافق
الخدميه الاساسيه طيب هلا زال لديكم اي
امل في العثور على ناجين سيد عدنان
طبعا هذا جهود الانقاذ هي من تقوم بها
الدفاع المدني وكذلك زملائه الهلال الاحمر
العربي السوري من خلال تقديم الاسعافات
الاوليه للناجين تركيزنا الان
كما هو تقديم العون الاغاثي للذين الان
يحتجون العراء من خلال الدعم مراكز
الايواء التي تستضيفهم هذه اللحظه النتيجه
كما تعرف
البرد وغيرها من للاسف الشديد
وغيرها جعل من ظ حتى هذه المراكز الايواء
الصعبه نحاول تقديم ما يمكن تقديمه في هذا
الجانب هناك جهود
ومبادرات قامت بها دول وكذلك منظمات
للتخفيف من هذه المعاناه سواء في في شمال
او شرق او غرب
المناطق التي تاثرت بهذا الزلزال طيب
تحدثنا قبل قليل عن شرح الامكانيات سيد
عدنان
ويعني هل نحن نتحدث هنا عن عن شحف
الامكانيات لاتساع الرقعه الجغرافيه لهذا
الزلزال وبالتالي انتم امام تحدي كبير ام
ان جحا الامكانيات بسبب قله ربما الدعم
المساعده
ربما ايضا التحرك الدولي لم يكن على مستوى
الازمه البالغه وصعوبه ايضا بالحدث ام
ماذا الى ماذا تعزوا شح هذه الامكانيات
التحدي التحدي ياتي ليس فقط من هذه
الكارثه او هذه الماسه التحدي ان البلد
تعالى من اكثر من 12 عاما من الصراع انهك
انهك معظم المنشات الاساسيه وخاصه الطبيه
يعني الان عندما ينقل الجرحى لا يوجد دواء
لا يوجد مواد جراحيه
حاولنا نحن وغيرنا من المنظمه التقديم في
هذا الجانب ولكن هناك شحاء ولذلك قامت
بدعوتها او باحضار بعض ما يمكن احضاره
لتلك المستشفيات وخاصه المنتجات الرئيسيه
التي استقبلت الجرحى لبعض الجراحيه
للتخفيف من هذه المعاناه
الامكانيه تتكلم عن بلد اليوم قبل هذه
الكارثه
هناك 15 مليون حسب الاحصائيات بحاجه
لمساعده ليس فقط مساعده
المساعدات العاليه ولكن الاساسيه التي
مياه حاولنا خلال فتره الازمه انه نوفر
نوفر
الخدمه في هذه الجانب ولكن في الاول
والاخير نحن منظمه انسانيه مهما بدانا من
جهد
نقطه في محيط ان يكون هناك تحشد حقيقي
للازمه السوريه سواء من خلال هذه الكارثه
او بعدها